[Music]
let's shrink an elephant to the size of
a mouse and enlarge a mouse and make it
the size of an elephant because this is
our video and we want to see what
happens
first our now tiny elephant stumbles
around and then drops dead
tiny elephant buddy is very cold frozen
to death in minutes
our giant mouse looks very uncomfortable
for a moment and then it explodes
leaving hot mouse insides everywhere
why
because of size we are optimized to
function precisely for the size we are
and would die horribly in any other
environment
but why exactly
why does our mouse explode and can we do
this to our elephant too if we try hard
[Music]
life on this planet is based on cells
cells do vary in size but they're pretty
similar in their dimensions across all
species
a blue whale doesn't have bigger cells
than a hummingbird just a lot more often
cells have to do a lot of stuff to stay
alive and they need energy to be able to
do so to get this energy animal cells
convert food and oxygen into usable
chemical energy
this happens in our mitochondria the
powerhouse of the cell
they're like little coal engines that
spit out tiny atp batteries which the
cell can use for almost everything it
needs to do
just like an engine mitochondria get
really hot while working
in human skin cells they reach a
scorching 50 degrees celsius
and some of our cells have up to 2000
mitochondria which are radiating their
heat into the cell
so being alive generates a lot of heat
the more cells you have the more heat
your body generates in total
if our bodies didn't find ways of losing
this heat we would be cooked from the
inside and die
but this is a problem for bigger animals
because of the way bodies change as
living beings scale up
animals have three properties here that
are important
their length their outside or skin and
their insides like organs bones and
hopes and dreams
the thing that's hard to wrap your head
around is that when things grow their
insides grow faster than their outsides
imagine a fleshy cube
if you double the length of its sides
its surface and volume do not double
in fact the surface is now four times
the original size and the volume of the
cube eight times the original size
which is called the square cube law and
has been annoying nature for billions of
years
so why is this a problem for big animals
because heat can only leave an object
via its surface
so if we make our mouse the size of an
elephant or 60 times longer it has 3 600
times more surface from which to lose
heat but it has 216 000 times more
volume filled with trillions and
trillions of new hot mitochondria that
produce more heat
a lot more insides not that much more
skin
our mouse is very dead very fast
but big things like elephants exist so
how do they deal with the heat
for one they evolved ways to get rid of
energy more easily like huge flat ears
that have a lot of surface where heat
can
escape but that's not enough nature's
solution is actually very elegant
elephant cells are much much slower than
mice cells
the bigger an animal is the less active
its cells are
if we classify animals by their
metabolic rates and compare that to
their overall mass it's clearly visible
it's not 100 accurate but it is a good
rule of thumb
elephants are huge meat sacks filled
with trillions and trillions of little
coal ovens so they keep the ovens just
active enough to keep them running and
never at full power
their whole metabolism is slow things
move at a nice chill pace
small animals need to go the exact
opposite way if you're small you have a
lot of surface area compared to not a
lot of volume
you don't have a lot of cell ovens and
lose the heat they produce very fast
so very tiny mammals came up with a very
extreme solution
meet the etruscan shrew the smallest
mammal on earth a mole like thing that's
more closely related to hedgehogs than
to mice
with a body length of four centimeters
it only weighs about 1.8 grams as much
as a paperclip it's a tiny ridiculous
being
it would basically cool off immediately
so it sells run on overdrive to stay
warm
its tiny ovens are filled at maximum
capacity its heart beats up to 1200
times a minute and it breathes up to 800
times a minute
this creates an extreme need for energy
so the shrew has to eat constantly after
only four hours without food it starves
to death
and while an african elephant consumes
around four percent of its body weight
in food each day our shrew needs 200 of
its body weight in food a day just to
survive
imagine having to eat 2 000 big macs a
day more than one a minute fun for a
while but then not so much
so a cubic centimeter of shrew needs 40
times more food than a cubic centimeter
of elephant if an elephant cells
suddenly become as active as the cells
of a shrew a crazy amount of heat would
be generated all the liquids in the
elephant would suddenly start boiling
and then it would explode in an
impressive explosion of steaming hot
burning elephant parts
in reality before an explosion occurred
the proteins making up our cells would
probably be denatured and stop producing
heat
but a meat explosion is much more fun
than melting an elephant into a massive
hot goo
regardless the scaling of the speed of
metabolism happens everywhere even in
places we don't expect like pregnant
women
a baby in the womb of its mother behaves
as if it were a part of her
its cells have about the same metabolic
rate the same speed of life as its
mother's organs
it is truly a part of a bigger hole
rather than an individual
until it's not anymore
the very moment a baby is born a switch
is flipped and all its internal
processes speed up rapidly
36 hours after birth the baby's cells
have the same activity rate as a mammoth
size
babies literally transition from being
an organ to being an individual in mere
hours
but there's one thing where big and
small things are very similar heartbeats
mammals tend to have a similar amount of
heartbeats over their lifetime typically
around 1 billion
so while the shrew and elephant are very
different they share a similar number of
heartbeats over the course of their
lives
their speed of life is the opposite and
somehow still the same
and for a video in which we made
elephants explode for no good reason
this is the most romantic ending we
could come up with